der wettlauf um ein corona impfstoff
geht also weiter und wir versuchen jetzt
ein paar fragen zu klären die sich rund
um das impfen stellen in neu ulm ist mit
zugeschaltet professor thomas mertens
der vorsitzende der ständigen
impfkommission dass es die organisation
die impf empfehlung abgibt hallo herr
professor maertens
die gretchenfrage zuerst wie sicher ist
aus ihrer aus ihrem blickwinkel der
impfstoff die beiden impfstoffe die
jetzt in den startlöchern stehen
ich halte die impfstoffe für sicher ich
kann die menschen verstehen die unruhig
sind weil die dinge tatsächlich schnell
gegangen sind
man muss aber dazu sagen dass zwar die
entwicklung der impfstoffe schnell
gegangen ist aber das natürlich schon
jahrelang an der technologie geforscht
wird und dass wir sehr gut über die
wirkungsweise und funktion von einem
bescheid wissen
insofern ist es nicht so dass diese
technologie jetzt gerade für den
impfstoff entwickelt worden ist sie wird
nur daraufhin angepasst
trotzdem ist es so dass die impfstoff
entwicklung und prüfung jetzt sehr
schnell gegangen ist aber das hat
natürlich den hintergrund dass wir alle
nicht glauben dass wir noch jetzt jahre
ohne impfstoff zu bringen können und
sollten und insofern sind wir jetzt an
der schwelle es auch anzuwenden
sie sagen dass gerade das musste
natürlich sehr schnell gehen in
windeseile wenn man das mit sonstigen
zulassungen vergleicht aber über die
sorge zum beispiel was langzeitfolgen
einer solchen impfung angeht kann man
doch im moment noch eigentlich nicht
sagen oder nein das kann man nicht sagen
aber das ist auch keine besonderheit bei
diesem stoff wenn man das genau
betrachtet kann man das ja weder bei
anderen neuen den stoffen noch auch bei
anderen medikamenten wirklich am anfang
denn natürlich wenn sie sie machen
studien um die sicherheit zu
gewährleisten das ist ja auch
verpflichtend vernünftig und unbedingt
erforderlich aber dann kommt immer der
zeitpunkt wo man ein präparat sei es im
stoff oder medikament auch anwenden muss
und dann kann es in der medizin immer
sein dass es auch noch nebenwirkungen
gibt die man anfangs nicht erkennen
konnte und das ist auch hier so aber
diese besonderheit die man jetzt im
augenblick fällt gerade bei diesem
impfstoff ist eigentlich auch bei
anderen medikamenten und impfstoffen
durchaus gegeben
können sie einem laien erklären
möglichst einfach wie diese impfung
jetzt funktionieren wird also was das
für ein impfstoff ist das vergleichbar
mit einer masernimpfung sage ich mal
grippeschutzimpfung wo man ein bisschen
was von dem erreger bekommt nein
überhaupt nicht
man hat hier tatsächlich jetzt für einen
menschlichen impfstoff zum ersten mal
diese sogenannte mrsa oder boten rna
technik verwendet sie beruht auf dem
prinzip dass man ein solches kurzes
stück rna also eine so wollen
information über ein virus protein
zusätzlich von außen in zellen einbringt
und dann innerhalb der zelle die normale
eiweißproduktion maschinerie der zelle
nutzt um dort dieses virus kleine virus
proteine herstellen zu lassen von der
zelle und das ist in der tat neue und
dann kann der organismus gegen dieses
eiweiß was dann gebildet wurde eine
immunantwort machen
jetzt komme ich zurück auch die berühmte
frage inwieweit das einen eingriff in
die genetik des menschen bedeutet das
tut es nicht weil unser genom liegt im
zellkern und ist in der form einer dna
dort festgeschrieben und normalerweise
wird dann an der dna immer wieder mal
kleine stücke abgeschrieben in rna
umgeschrieben und dann wird diese rna
aus dem zellkern aber an genau die
gleichen orte transportiert an denen
auch jetzt diese zusätzliche rna in
wiederum ein
protein übersetzt wird so dass ich sagen
muss es handelt sich bei der herstellung
dieses impfstoffes sehr wohl um einen
gentechnischen prozess ganz klar aber
innerhalb des geimpften findet dann
keine veränderung des genoms stadt das
kann man so sicher sagen herr professor
mertens eine kurze frage bitte um ganz
kurze antwort wem raten sie sich impfen
zu lassen
nun auf jeden fall den die ein
berechenbares hohes risiko für schwere
erkrankung oder tod haben sehen sie wenn
jemand über 70 ist vor erkrankt ist und
vielleicht noch zuckerkrank ist dann
kann man rechnen dass sein risiko zu
sterben war zwischen 10 und 20 prozent
liegt und es ist nicht sinnvoll als
mensch dagegen ein hypothetisches also
ein wirkliches aber in der gar nicht
bekanntes risiko auf zuwegen also ich
rate allen auf jeden fall die ein sehr
reales risiko haben sich auch impfen zu
lassen und ich würde mich auch aus den
genannten gründen ins belassen
herzlichen dank herr professor merkens
für ihre versuche zumindest das einfach
zu erklären da geschah ja danke